and then we have another guy Larry
Ellison billionaire guy you know 50
billion plus he started Oracle
he says debt has never made any sense to
me how can a person be there and just
vanish and just not be there
was he stoned
[Music]
dude I got a lot of stuff to talk about
today do you yeah I'm excited to I'm
excited about you know I want to say
something
um
people have been a little bit spoiled by
this podcast I gotta say like I said a
little spoiled
um people just expect that every single
episode is gonna be a banger every
single episode is just gonna just bring
a little smile to your face put a little
money in your pocket
give you a little nugget of wisdom that
you might be able to say to somebody
throughout the day and they think you
are you or that wise and I think people
got a little spoiled and not every
podcast
is gonna be a banger not every podcast
is going to deliver not every day is
gonna be one of those days
some days you just don't have it
but today is not that day today we have
it you have it too I just I just looked
at the document I saw what you had on
there I don't know what anything about
these topics I'm excited to hear what
you got let me bring up the first topic
rich people
and health and I'm talking like really
and the reason I was interested in this
is Sam Altman all the rage right now Sam
Altman you know uh helped run Y
combinator and then now is the CEO of
openai and he's in the news because he
did this like thing in front of the
Senate and he was very endearing he's
he's incredibly likable not and and he's
also very successful
I read this article and it said
something about two things that stood
out it said something like
he put all of his liquid net worth so he
said in this article he goes I basically
put 100 of my liquid net worth into two
companies the first is helion energy he
invested his own money 375 million
dollars of his own money and the second
business uh was called retro it's a
health company he invested 180 million
dollars so that kind of caught my eye
and by the way remember we did a segment
on Sam I don't know a couple months ago
and it was because I had read this thing
that Sam Altman led the round in helium
with 300 something million dollars and I
started texting people being like
how much money does Sam have that he's
investing 300 million into a single
company uh is he does he have a fund
does he secretly have a fund and some
people are like no I he might have a
fund I wouldn't be a surprise but I
think this was I think this was personal
right and it just didn't make sense and
we did this whole Deep dive because that
one number just sounded outrageous and
now this is some new information that
he's saying yeah I actually did put all
my eggs in two baskets uh two two eggs
in one basket in a recent article the
quote is that or there's a quote from
him admitting he goes I basically put
all of my liquid net worth in this into
that and so retro health kind of caught
my eye and then in another article that
just came out he said that uh he was
talking about like his daily routine and
he talked about his uh like he's
obsessed with like everyone used to talk
about how he was obsessed with the end
of the world so he has like this
property that has like gas masks and all
this other [__] whatever that's
interesting but we've talked about that
but then he also says that he's really
obsessed with anti-aging and he goes
it's mostly simple stuff I try to eat
healthy I exercise I sleep enough and I
take Foreman
that caught my eye one of these does not
belong yeah one of these is things my my
mom advises me to do all of these are
things my mom advised me to do except
for one yes so the metformin they caught
my eye and also that he put 300 million
dollars of his own money he goes I take
metformin and he goes I also hope to one
day take retro Health's medicines which
they haven't come out with yet have you
have you heard of Metformin do you know
what this is I've heard about this
because um vitalik the guy from ethereum
he was on someone's podcast and they
they instead of asking about crypto at
one point they were like let's talk
about other stuff you're super into like
oh longevity you're interested in health
and he's like yeah I'm like kind of
interested in it you know I've taken
metformin and rap what's the other one
called rap something rap rhaps yeah yeah
like that that's another longevity drug
I don't know much and he's like he's
like I I don't think he said he takes it
regularly he's like but I'm interested
in that I'd like to I'd like to learn
more about that so uh about a year ago I
was telling you about semi-glue tied and
I'm like this drug is interesting I
think it's going to be popular and it
got very popular I don't know say what
you really said what did I say is a
miracle drug you're like dude I'm
injecting myself with this [__]
unbelievable I don't crave candy anymore
yeah I'm losing so much weight this
thing's crazy yeah you're right I tested
it out I don't take it anymore but I'm
I'm like a guinea pig I'll eject myself
with anything to try it out and so I
tried it out and so I got a little bit
more interested in this and so
everything I'm about to say I want to
preference this that's saying I don't
know [__] I've listened to like a
handful of Pop podcasts and read like
some studies that's about that's the the
education I have here but basically
metformin is similar-ish to semi-glutide
in that it was created in the 90s or was
created before that but got FDA approved
in the 90s and the whole stick behind it
is that it helps uh insulin uh
sensitivity which basically just means
uh when you eat sugar or crave sugar or
whatever your blood sugar spikes and if
you're diabetic that's why this drug is
important that's basically all I know
but the reason why this is important for
longevity is what people have found is
that there is a huge correlation between
your blood sugar spiking and how long
you can live so basically when your
blood sugar spikes like a huge amount as
if you just ate tons of sugar and if
that spikes a lot that's correlated with
living less or not as long as it being
like stable all the time so the reason
why some of these I think they're called
glps uh glucose like it basically limits
like your glucose spiking is what these
drugs do that's like the dumb Meathead
version which is all I know of
explaining it and the reason why these
drugs are interesting is because they
were given to diabetics and like oh hey
your sugar uh blood sugar isn't spiking
Oh weird a lot of these people are
living like kind of a long time what the
hell is going on and then that's when
they're like man this drug actually
might be good for making you live longer
because it's correlated with keeping
your blood sugar low which is also
correlated with making you live for a
little bit longer and so that's what
this drug is and I started Googling it
and all these like and they're there's
definitely downsides but all these like
biohackers and also like these really
rich guys I'm talking like 500 million
billion dollar folks it seems like a ton
of them are taking this drug do you know
anyone who's taking this
personally I don't know anyone who's
taking it but I don't
um ask and I would bet that
a good number of our friends I would say
like I would bet that 20 of our friends
who kind of fit this category of like
they um they went into Chuck E cheese
they got all the tickets and now they
don't want to leave uh it's basically
like really rich people who have won at
life and now they only think about big
picture things and they're trying not to
die because uh they got they got it
pretty good and so I would say it's it's
probably very common in those circles
and so like I first was interested in
how like wealthy people care about
health like years ago 10 years ago I
read the biography of John Rockefeller
and John Rockefeller uh you know was he
probably died in 1930 or for 1940 so he
basically in the book they're like he
chooses his food super slow and he makes
sure that it's like fully liquid before
he swallows and like when he was like 80
years old he basically was like a
vegetarian and if he wanted to eat a
piece of chocolate he would like call
his doctor and say hey is it okay if I
have this and he was like anal about
that and then I listened to Ben Wilson's
how to take over the world with Tom
Edison Thomas Edison and he did this
it's some similar stuff and he was like
I eat light and I try not I don't
overeat I take a nap once a day like he
like all these Health stuff so I started
thinking like
that's interesting so like wealthy
people have always cared about it the
difference between today's wealthy
people and in 19 or 1880 is basically
like we have a bit more science and so
I've been obsessed with like what some
of these wealthy people are doing and I
want to read you a few quotes and tell
you about a few interesting things that
people are doing like incredibly wealthy
people for example Peter Thiel he has
the most Peter teal quote I've ever
heard on death
he says there there are these people who
say that death is natural and it's just
part of life and I think I think nothing
further can be from the truth
I he goes um I I believe that the
acceptance of death is a psychological
defense mechanism and I dismiss it as
being weird and sociopathic and then he
talks about like how like living forever
will be bad for the economy he goes
that's okay even if there are problems
with that it's better than being dead
and so he like talks about how he takes
HGH human growth hormone and he's doing
this other thing called parabiosis which
I don't know exactly what that is but
he's spending uh well and that's like
where the the rumor of him being a blood
boy so para biologist is like where you
take younger people's blood and put it
in your body to like right live long but
that's all I know about it and then we
have another guy Larry Ellison
billionaire guy you know 50 billion plus
I started Oracle
he says death has never made any sense
to me how can a person be there and just
vanish and just not be there
was he stoned it's like you know how
like a baby is it takes them like six
months to realize that like when you
cover your eyes like you're you're like
you cover like your own eyes it's like
I'm here uh he's it's kind of like he's
like Benjamin buttons for that like you
know he's going in reverse
I'm stunned by a game of peekaboo and
then there's uh one more person that I
thought was interesting that we've
talked about Brian Johnson we've had him
on the Pod he has this thing blueprint
which we all know about but two
interesting changes have come from that
so the the background is Brian Johnson
started Braintree which owns venmo and
all this other stuff he sold it he's
likely a billionaire and he does this
thing called The Blueprint where he like
is spending two or three million dollars
a year and he like
doesn't eat sugar he only eats plants he
exercises in a certain way but he
measures all of it like uh religiously
and you could go on and see it well I
found two things interesting with that
that now that he's getting popular which
I think you and I get like
point five percent credit for him being
popular we were we were early on that
train which it gives me Pride but one uh
one interesting thing is there's a
subreddit now called like the blueprint
and there's people mimicking what he's
doing and I've been paying attention to
the subreddit it only has like 3 000
people but the engagement is really
really high and there's people testing
it and when I read their posts I'm like
I don't know entirely that if like being
a vegan is good or not good for you but
the way that you guys are describing
this I'm all in you know what I mean
like it's very intoxicating and whenever
you see stuff and content like that it I
you I can kind of feel like it's going
to be popular and the second thing
that's popped up
is go to uh rejuvenationolympics.com
so like okay what are the what are the
Rejuvenation Olympics is it what it
sounds like I mean how does this work so
there's the leaderboard of which Brian
Johnson is number one but there's
thousands of people by the way the
tagline is hilarious what is it so it
says so Rejuvenation Olympics where you
win by never crossing the Finish Line
that's good that's amazing right that's
good well done whoever that was nice one
so the whole competition is to see is
who can decrease their biological age
compared to their chronological age so
who can like and I don't understand how
they make up like the the rules but it's
hundreds of people and they're uploading
like their pre-results and then they're
like most recent results and and like I
don't I think I don't know if there's a
prize other than bragging and
potentially not dying but it's really
fascinating do you see that list it's
cool looking right yeah so basically
it'll be like Brian Johnson his
chronological age 45 years old and then
it's ranked on his improvement from the
Baseline which I'm not sure exactly what
that means but I'm guessing it's
basically what his his chronological age
versus biological age and What's the
diff is it kind of my my guess What's
the diff yeah yeah
get it to death but anyway all this
stuff about like what like you know
there's like what's that phrase like
whatever like Brian Johnson created this
thing so oh he created it okay some guy
uh Oliver
um
did it yeah so you know I also have a
handsome indianolympics.com yeah I'm
currently number one we're taking
content taking nominations
but dude it is like fascinating like
what's that phrase like whatever like
the Nerds are doing on the weekends it's
gonna be popular it's kind of the same
thing with like billionaires which is
like whatever billionaires are doing
like everyone else is going to want to
do and uh this stuff is fascinating to
me I I don't know like I don't know like
a if any of this is true or [__] and
B like can any normal person ever have
access to this stuff I don't know
but I know that there's something here
and I'm not but I'm not sure how it's
gonna play out well okay let's let's do
a couple of these uh kind of like
takeaways I think you're right that
this stuff like metformin and other
anti-aging or reverse aging drugs are
gonna get more popular
I also think that by the way
metformin and semi-gluto I don't think
they're in the same category at all but
kind of in that they're like diabetic
stuff that now regular people are using
semi-glutide it's sold out like if like
you if you globally yeah like you can't
it takes even like if you're wealthy it
takes weeks to get it like so that has
happened already like there's on Tick
Tock so like Tick Tock I think is like a
good barometer of what like the average
person is doing like Lady Gaga what had
a video and she looked skinny and they
called and like the top comment was like
damn she's got that ozempic face because
apparently if you lose a lot of weight
really quickly so like people are
already like using that as like
vernacular and phrasing so it's already
there
totally
um the second thing I would say is I had
never even heard of this concept of
measuring your biological age versus
chronological age like I didn't even
know there was a there was such a thing
that you could separate those two
numbers uh but now that I know I don't
want to unknow it and actually I'm very
curious as to what my biological versus
chronological age is I'm sure there are
many many people who are curious about
that and so I could see somebody
creating a testing service that's either
kind of like a Everly well whatever
that's like uh you know draw your blood
and give you some result or like even a
clinic like a dexa scan place where you
go and they take you through the battery
of tests that you need to do in order to
give you this report and uh so I could
see that being uh you know a business or
Trend that that takes place in the
future that's kind of exciting and I
think that the beauty of that model is
basically
um
you can you could go low price on that
test because I think you get your upsell
will be so strong
um once you give someone their number
and they're sort of thinking about the
big picture uh I think you could upsell
thousands and thousands of dollars worth
of either nutrition training medicine
some combination of of whatever Health
stuff if you had a low-cost like an at
Cost basically
um biological age test there's a company
that's doing it right now that I tried
out it's called inside tracker I first
heard about them because Andrew huberman
talks about them so I don't actually
know like the science behind it and it
could be complete junk I I don't I'm not
sure but because he endorsed it I was
like all right I'm interested but it's
called inside tracker and I do it about
twice a year and it's 600 and you go to
like Quest Diagnostics or LabCorp and
you get blood and then you get the
results in like a week but it's called
inside tracker it's 600 bucks or maybe
700 something like that still not like
crazy cheap but like once I saw my
biological age it was like a competition
so now every time every six months I'm
trying to like reduce it so what is your
difference what's your chronological
versus biological you have a big
difference or no yeah nine years so my
biological was uh 22 or 23 something
like that I'm 33. uh so it was it was I
I did pretty good yeah that's amazing
the only thing I had to work on was my
cholesterol I had higher cholesterol and
I don't even know like entirely what
cholesterol so what did you do you just
gave blood in order to do that yeah yeah
you give a fair amount of blood uh but
yeah you get blood because I thought
what Brian Johnson's doing he's
measuring like each organ individually
so he's doing he like what I'm doing is
like the JV team what he's doing is like
professional athletes
yeah he's he's like going overboard or I
don't know about overboard but you know
you know he's crazy right like he'll eat
like
the same meal every single day and it's
like nuts or uh like uh it's like a hot
oatmeal made of spinach it's like crazy
I saw this tweet so basically on May
15th this guy named Ben tweeted out that
on this one website that buys and sells
businesses there's a podcast for sale it
does 2.2 million in profit it's an
entrepreneur podcast the owner Works 20
hours a week recording seven podcasts so
it's one per day
the company only has three full-time
employees and it's a podcast that's been
around for uh 10 years
and it has nearly 4 000 episodes
and so
a I was figure trying to figure out
which podcast this is and I have a guess
of which I'm almost certain it is with
but this person has never confirmed it I
think it's entrepreneur on fire by John
Lee Dumas who's been on rpod and us on
his uh but I have no there's no
confirmation this is just a guess I
would bet
everything that it's him uh and then but
I've got to guess I don't get my life on
yeah but I have zero I have you know
it's not actually confirmed and the
second thing is he's asking
15 million dollars for this that's the
asking price so my question to you is
what do you think this is worth it's
hard because if you buy it
he's not coming with it correct so the
way if you guys Google uh like uh so the
guy's name is Ben tiglar so
t-i-g-g-e-l-a-a-r and you'll find his
tweet you get directed he's a good
follow by the way he has good like
buying businesses tweets so yeah like
his Twitter he'll link you to a thing
where you could see like the page that
uh that that you'll see a bunch of high
level details and then you can enter in
your information and then make you sign
an NDA we'll send you the whole deal
book I purposely didn't do the NDA part
so just so I could talk about it so I'm
only referencing what I saw on the deal
page which is like high level stuff so I
don't know if he goes with it uh by the
way if you go to his if you go to
entrepreneurs on Fire's website there's
a ticker at the top that shows uh
revenue for April 2023. you click it and
it'll tell you that uh in April we made
181 thousand six hundred and seven
dollars here's the full report and you
can see that since he launched it 10
years ago this podcast he says has
generated 19 million dollars in net
income them for him in the in the uh
I guess 11 years now since since it is
uh
since it has been launched that's pretty
stunning uh for for this podcast that I
would say is like a good podcast but
it's not like uh
it's not like one of these podcasts if I
said like name the podcast that you know
your favorite podcast in the world the
one that influences you the most the one
that what's the most one of the most
popular entrepreneurial podcasts I would
not name this one I don't think most
people would name this one and for this
podcast I've generated 19 million
dollars in net income since uh 2012 is
pretty pretty stunning and you can see
that it's basically 91 sponsorships
four percent courses four percent
affiliate two percent his book sales and
my my opinion and this has nothing to do
with John this has nothing to do with
his business I think that this podcast
is worth without him close to zero
just about close to zero and what is
interesting that's crazy
no I and I'll explain why because what
let's say that you own this what's gonna
happen you pay 15 million dollars what's
gonna happen like the first six months
without him like you're just gonna make
residual
revenue and or and then what he'll go
and start his own he'll go oh yeah well
no I think you're going to have a
non-compete here if he if you buy this
thing from first of all nobody's buying
this for 15 million those people what do
you think it's worth I think you could
buy this I think you could buy something
like this for five to six million if you
were serious about it
um you would have to be betting on two
things number one that the loyalty is to
the because I think what he does is
interviews correct I don't actually
listen to the Pod I think interviews
it's like 20 minute interviews so you I
think you have to bet that his listeners
are there to hear a certain type of
person come on and speak and you have to
be a good interviewer so they're not
there for John they're there for for uh
guest guest a b c d e
um you'd have to be betting that and
you'd have to be betting that he's not
going to go create a competing podcast
of the same ilk and draw away people who
are used to him there if you were to do
those two things
and you bought this at a two or three x
multiple of profits
I don't think that's insane I also don't
think it's what I would do like I don't
think I would make that bet but I don't
think that's an insane bet to buy it for
15 million I think is an insane move you
think what do you think he'll get
I think he's likely to get no offers
period
um because the number the subset of
buyers is pretty small for something
like this and I think he could sell it
for between one to three x profit dude
and I don't know why he would post it
maybe we'll be wrong I don't know why he
would post it on this site because a guy
like Ben found it and immediately people
were in the comments were like oh it's
this one this episode had like they show
all your Revenue I know how many
episodes it has like this is just like
the easiest thing ever you know what I
mean uh like they like totally guessed
what it was and I think that that's
crazy I I I that's it was a tough mood
and it's also like we appeal
to entrepreneurial people who buy and
sell businesses and so you're just
getting like your audience is the one
that's gonna out you you know what I'm
saying does he say uh does he say how
much uh how many subscribers like how
many subscribers he has or how big the
podcast is yeah in the in the listing I
think it says how many downloads it's
either gets a year or a month but I
believe it does it say what it what it
is uh
uh it just says 145 million listens
so I don't know how you would calculate
that you divide that by at least too
many episodes there's like 14 episodes
or something so but it's something like
a one to two million downloads per month
on and that's a daily pod so I don't
know how much each one gets but
anyway kind of an interesting thing if
someone could sell this like a
personality driven podcast and then that
reverts to not personality driven that
this would be very very very fascinating
yeah I I'm very curious to see how this
plays out I don't know how personality
driven he is I think that's that that's
the question like if you're um like if
it's the Tim Ferriss podcast it's
literally called the Tim Ferriss podcast
and I would say that the that Tim is a
very branded interviewer
um you know his voice his style his face
is the thumbnail like I think that's
like impossible to sell uh entrepreneurs
on fire with John Lee Dumas I don't know
I think it's I think it's possible but
I'm not sure what the upside would be
you know you'd have to come in and be
like great here's what I'm gonna do
let's see can I uh how can I make my
investment more more valuable can I add
more episodes well he's doing one a day
already so probably probably not much
room there uh can I launch auxiliary
products well he's already got his
journal his book his course his
affiliate links it's like like no he's
kind of squeezed all the the
monetization juice it's not like there's
obvious things that he just didn't do uh
for this thing uh can I grow the
audience not pretty much impossible to
grow a podcast audience just by Brute
Force it's not like a really clear clear
way to do that so I don't know why you
would buy based on that I think based
based on the fact that there's not very
clear growth levers I think that makes
it a tough budget I guess we will see
but he can tell us what he can tell us
why we're wrong maybe tweet that as John
tell us uh why somebody should buy this
for 15 million and how they're going to
make you know three times their money in
uh in the next you know five years on on
that
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobbled
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
the McGregor documentary you watched it
yeah really good it didn't talk about
his business stuff which I thought was
kind of I wish it would have but it was
really good what do you think about him
okay so my is so I used to love Conor
McGregor like at a given point in time
he would have been by far my favorite
athlete you know combination of
entertainment uh you know success and uh
the mindset so like you know I thought
that that was like just an amazing
combination I had never really seen
before and his run up from guy who was
basically a
Apprentice plumber on welfare to richest
athlete the highest earning athlete in
the world global global Star 28 world
champion in like a six-year period was
that six years of following that was
unbelievable to watch that kind of rags
to richest story he was kind of like the
equivalent of a redneck but in Ireland
is what I've realized like watching that
documentary I was like oh you like are
really good looking but you are like a
trashy like redneck person like that's
that's basically what you were yeah
exactly exactly and he's had many
documentaries actually he's had many
because from the beginning he was
filming or people were filming him
because he has like a sort of Charisma
and a magnetism about him and he had a
lot of self-belief he had like an
unbelievable amount of self-belief where
he's like
hey record this record this and they're
like who are you what you're not even
you're an amateur fighter like why are
we recording you exactly because I'm
gonna be the best and so he's actually
had I think three different things on
Netflix this was the latest one
um couple of thoughts number one
special people
are nuts
and you gotta be a little nuts in order
to do what you're doing and he's openly
admitted to being a bit nuts in fact he
has this quote in the documentary where
he's like I'm like Vincent van Gogh I've
lost my mind to the game uh I don't I
don't know nothing about else except for
this game every moment every thought is
about
as about this game I have lost my mind
to it and I like I wouldn't have it any
other way there was a there was an
interview where someone was like hey
what do you think about the Manchester
United game and he was like oh it was
good you know it's great look I'm gonna
be honest I don't I don't even know what
game you're talking about like I I don't
know anything about soccer I you could
ask me about politics I don't know
anything about it uh I I watch none of
this all I care about is fighting right
exactly so he had like a laser phone
that's all on the come up and then
he makes it he becomes the high starting
athlete in the world he's uh creates
this whiskey brand that sells for 600
million dollars and he makes maybe 200
million out of that you think that you
think that those that number's right
yeah I'm pretty sure that's right
um and then I uh and then he's got his
suit line then he's got his his McGregor
FAST program he's got his uh recovery
spray he's got like all these other
businesses right and so he um and then
you know he starts to lose and he starts
to get in trouble with the law and he
starts to sort of he becomes his Larger
than Life Persona so he's an interesting
guy he's got a little bit of a screw
this I thought two things stood out to
me from the documentary one was
early McGregor mindset was the best so
the way they filmed this was they would
take present day footage of him going
through something and they would splice
it with like before he was famous the
things this guy would say and they put
it together and when you watch it
together it's like
the perfect mindset it's like adversity
and then him saying exactly how to deal
with this adversity or how to avoid the
this this problem
but the problem was all of the mindset
stuff was from him before it was like
you know him 10 years ago and um I think
you know the the editing made it look
like a sort of in a way like very
admirable but I I think what's
interesting is actually how much it
changes like the mindset that got him
there isn't necessarily the mindset he
still has because so like at the
beginning his mindset overcame his
environment like nobody from Ireland had
ever made it he didn't have a proper you
know like you know training setup he you
know he was not even in the UFC and his
mind it was like Mind Over Matter
and then the problem is like then the
matter got so big he's sitting on a
Lamborghini yacht he's got you know
everybody kissing his butt and you know
he doesn't have to wake up at four in
the morning and go run anymore like then
at some point the search his own success
became his demise in a way I think this
is some poetic in that the second thing
I thought was he had a quote that I
really loved I think is very relatable
to me at least
they go so what happened did you just
you know you stopped training everybody
says that remember you got rich you
stopped training he goes no no
in training I was a hundred percent
committed that was a hundred percent I
gave every ounce of my effort in the
training sessions
it was outside the training sessions and
I was not 100 committed I was 75
committed he's like but that was the
difference he's like you know
um you know the it like here I was
willing to sweat but outside of this you
know I would uh I would tell myself you
shouldn't eat that then I ate it yeah
you shouldn't drink that and I drank it
you should you should you're gonna wake
up at this time I don't wake up you're
gonna go to sleep on time I don't go to
sleep on time he's like and those little
these like those were little losses and
those little losses or it could have
been a small win and instead it was a
small loss and I was taking those small
losses outside of training and he goes
that's what deteriorates the mind it
weakens the mind and he's like it
infiltrates your your brain these small
losses they don't individually they
don't seem like anything but they add up
one day after another next after next
and my mind became weaker and doubt
started to creep in for the first time
and uh you know I started a slip outside
of the training and I thought
man that's such a good lesson and frame
for like since I watched that now all
day I see opportunities I'm like this is
either going to be a small win or a
small loss it's not gonna no one's even
gonna know besides me only I know that
this situation is even occurring you
know I'm feeding my daughter she's
eating mac and cheese I've eaten clean
all day she doesn't eat the food and now
there's mac and cheese in front of my
face or you know do I take that bite or
do I not take that bite it's a small win
or a small loss uh you know going to
sleep on time it's a small win or a
small loss and since that documentary I
started racking up small Vines I
realized how many small losses I was
taking and I decided not to take those
out you want to know something funny
yeah I remember that exact where he goes
there was times I was supposed to wake
up I didn't wake up I knew I shouldn't
have ate that and I ate it I hate that
there was it was so relatable there's
this you know the thing about him is
there's all these small details about
him that were really fascinating for
example he has a tattoo on his arm and
it says slow low is smooth and smooth is
fast and I thought that I thought I was
like that's just a really good phrase
It's a military phrase I don't know if
you've ever heard that no I didn't know
that and I thought that that was like um
I think it's like a Navy phrase or
something it was a guy who worked for us
I was in the Army he used to say that he
used to say uh I know we want to go fast
but remember slow is smooth and smooth
is fast and uh he goes that's how they
teach us when I think it's for rowing uh
like like if you try to just thrash
while you're rowing you're trying to go
fast but you're not actually gonna go
fast what's what works in rowing is
clean smooth aligned Strokes by the
whole team and the boat goes fast and
like that's kind of what you want to do
yeah and he was fascinating and he also
um
I don't know if he explicitly said this
but there was this one time where he
does this famous thing in one of his I
think his first UFC fight he knocked
someone out and at the end typically one
fighter of the 16 gets a 50 000 bonus uh
if they have a good knockout and at the
end of the interview he goes Dana 50 G's
baby like he's calling out dated to give
him the 50 G's and he was the first
person I think to do that which is
pretty funny and then afterwards they go
all right fine you got the 50 G's and
they go what are you gonna spend it on
he goes he goes dude I was under welfare
last week but I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna
buy a suit I'm gonna buy this and then
the next fight Ariel hawani who we've
had in the Pod interviews him he goes
Connor I saw that you just showed up at
a Louis Vuitton like suitcase he goes
and he said something like I gotta buy
the best I feel like the best and if you
look at his life I'm typically not a guy
I don't like to spend a lot of money I
don't like uh you know flashy stuff
but he does something interesting where
he starts leveling up his life to where
he's like and like he'll wear like if
like you and I if we think about like
when we were younger we're like well
businessman has to have a suitcase and a
tie and then now we're older we're like
who the [__] would wear that you look
like a fool he still kind of plays that
part so when he goes to a business
meeting he wears a suit and I look him
in that suit and I'm like yeah dude you
look like I trust you more like for some
re like you know there's like you look
more like a custom fitted tailored
three-piece suit to the you know to the
to the nines yeah and my takeaway from
that was like you know like I used to
dismiss like a certain dress or certain
clothing or certain cars like but like
man sometimes when you level up your
lifestyle it's almost like there's this
old story about a guy who wanted to sell
like a Picasso and he's like come to my
warehouse look at the Picasso and the
guy looks at it and then there's and he
wasn't very impressed and there's
another story where a guy takes him to
this like small theater where there's
classical music playing and he dim the
lights and he goes look at this Picasso
now and you sit down at this beautiful
like velvet chair and you like right oh
man like it's so much more beautiful now
and that's kind of like what he did with
his life he surrounded himself with like
this fancy [__] which typically I think
is bad but for some reason I realized
it's kind of cool to like surround
yourself with stuff and act as if it's
like no like I'm here and I I must act
as if or act uh you know act like I am
here yeah he's talked about that uh in
the in the thing he say you know what do
you want uh you know do you want this
you want that he goes
he goes I like I want the common thing
is he rejects the question he rejects
the premise in many many questions so
one example is they're talking about
wanting and he goes he goes that's the
problem want you want this want that I
already have I always act from I I
already have all these things I already
have the Championships I already have
all the money I already have all this
that's why I walked away I walked this
way I carry myself this way versus
wanting is just pointing out that you
don't have and he he's like he's like
you know so from the very beginning I
carried myself this way and he talks
about like um
uh he talks about like
uh in rejecting the question somebody I
remember once he was fighting Aldo and
they're like on this world tour and
they're just talking mad [__] to each
other the whole time and it was so it
got so like kind of was basically
bullying this guy verbally and uh one of
the they go on some TV show some good
morning America type show and they're
like all right well you know we've heard
you guys say this but okay let's play
let's do it a little different Connor
what's one thing you you'd like about
Aldo or you respect about Aldo let's
let's change it up and uh he just looks
at the guy the Good Morning America
person he goes this is not a therapy
session I am here to hurt this man and
like and whereas nine out of 10 people
you're on a TV show lights are bright
you're live on air and you kind of like
I will say whoever's got the stronger
frame is who wins and um
in most situations you just accept the
frame you're given the reporter says say
something nice to you say something nice
and later you kind of think back you're
like [__] I should have said this other
thing but like in the moment you got
taken over by their frame one thing I
notice about him and the way he speaks
is beautiful with words he comes into
the thing with his own frame and because
of that doesn't he doesn't get knocked
off course by any questions and often
we'll just reject the questions
altogether uh I want to read one quote
by the way about the about the Vincent
van Gogh thing he said
um he goes I heard Vincent van Gogh lost
his mind because this that's happened to
me but [__] it when the gold belt is
around my waist when my mother has a big
mansion well my girlfriend has a
different car for every day of the week
and when my kids kids have everything
that they ever want then it will pay
then I'll be happy I lost my mind
he's basically a rapper uh you know he's
a poet he says uh he's he's taught he's
so McGregor is about to fight the best
guy from Brazil and he goes If This Were
another time I'd storm his pavela which
is like a Brazilian Village he goes I'd
storm his pavela and pillage and take
what his mind he and his head would be
on a stake like he says these phrases
and there's another time where he gets
uh where he wins
um and afterwards Joe Rogan's
interviewing him and he like I I he must
have thought about these lines he says
Precision beats power and timing beats
speed and he says that really quick and
then like as an audience member you like
think about that line and like it just
certainly you're like wow that was like
that's a very insightful thing like he
says these really insightful things or
he'll say like I told you we didn't come
here to take part we came here to take
over uh you're like the study I'm like
dude you're a conqueror kind of but he's
a very flawed person when I watched a
documentary I'm like there's very
there's a lot of traits about him that I
you do not not like he's done a bunch of
bad things he's hypocritical in a bunch
of ways there's a bunch of things I
don't focus on those because what am I
going to take from that I well the
takeaway is nobody's perfect yeah like
everybody's flawed in their own ways the
things I do take are the things that are
going to serve me and one I remember all
right so you know when you go into
startup office uh in San Francisco every
engineer's got like multiple monitors
it's like uh it's kind of just like the
flex is like how many monitors you got
it's like you know the sysadmill I've
always got three most developers got at
least two so I used to sit there just on
my laptop I don't even have the big
monitor I was just on my little laptop
uh and I was like looking around I was
like maybe I need a big monitor so I got
a big monitor which was just my laptop I
plugged it in it's just bigger say okay
should I get a second monitor all right
I got a second monitor I was like what
the hell am I supposed to put on this I
don't I don't know I'm not trying to
look at two things at once that doesn't
even make sense so I just put and for
five years
there was one McGregor quote that just
was on my second monitor at all times I
only used it for this one quote and it
just said
at the end of the day you got to feel
some type of way so why not feel
unbeatable why not feel untouchable
and um that always stuck with me because
it was like
I do it just I don't know it resonated
it was like it's true at any given
moment you're gonna feel some type of
way so given I'm gonna feel some way why
don't I choose what would be the best
feelings I could choose and I'm gonna
feel that way I'm gonna choose how I
feel and I just left it there and I just
left it there for five years and it
really helped like starting yourself
could be kind of stressful and most days
I would say are like almost like down
days it's like uh
it's not growing it's not growing fast
enough it's growing too fast this shit's
breaking like there's a lot of reasons
to feel down in a startup and like that
one quote
changed my experience over those five
years so Steve Jobs if you read his
biography they someone coined this term
called the rat reality Distortion field
which basically is like regardless of
what the facts were outside of Steve's
brain
even though it showed like what you're
about to do is not likely he would
convince himself and others that it was
possible and they called it the reality
Distortion field and that's cool and all
but the reason why
this relates to Connor's when Steve Jobs
was doing all this stuff he didn't have
like a documentary as he was going
iPhones didn't really exist and like
easy footage didn't exist the reason why
this is cool for a business person is
because it's another example of which
that many people have this but it's a
good example of someone who does have
this but there's cameras there catching
the whole thing and so you'll see Connor
and he's about to fight Habib and Habib
wins the fight and anyone going into
that was like yeah habib's gonna sock
him he's gonna destroy him but Conor was
like he was so certain that he was going
to beat him that afterwards he's crying
and he's like I had planned like here's
how we were going to celebrate we're
gonna like he totally thought that he
was going to win when everyone else was
like
no way there's there's not a chance but
the fact that he believed it so much it
was really valuable even if the outcome
was the same and I thought that that was
really example but let me give you one
controversial or opinion about Conor as
well as a lot of other people
uh in this space
I predict that in 10 maybe 20 years but
probably 10 I think Conor will file for
bankruptcy and the reason I think that
is I've been you know how like you'll
read about like Floyd Mayweather has
made a billion dollars
or Conor McGregor made 100 million
dollars from boxing
I think all of that is 100 fake and it's
absolutely not true and the reason I
think this is this there's this guy
named Chael Sonnen he's a former fighter
now an analyst he went on Andrew Schultz
podcast and he goes I can promise you
that Floyd has never made a hundred
million dollars from one fight which is
what he says and I think that he is at
most made 100 million dollars
collectively in his career uh and he
goes the reason I think that is when a
lot of these people talk about
pay-per-view numbers and how much money
they're making
you can just say anything like not like
the CEO of DirecTV or whoever like
handles pay-per-views has never came out
and said this is how much money it made
like no one says that and what channel
goes he goes a lot of these athletes uh
if it's not like you know spoken by the
guy who paid the bill it's just
completely made up and they say that to
get more and I and he goes I know for a
fact a lot of it is fake do you think
do you have examples of people who you
know who have just blatantly lied like
you and I have one friend who like sold
a company and let's just I'm gonna make
up a fake number but it's something like
this the headlines if you Google it say
200 million dollars
I know it was 12. like there's like a
there's like I I know of stories like
that do you know of stories like that
where someone has just completely lied
well
I can't think of off top my head
somebody personally I know who's lied I
guess the the versions that I've seen of
this are almost like this the petty
crime version of this where they're like
um yeah I sold my company to whatever
it's like you got a job from them right
like you know it's uh
like yeah
how much cash was uh how much cash was
exchanged up front for the assets that
there's a difference
um like versus like we you know we sold
it to whatever Facebook and then you're
like okay cool you you got you got Aqua
hired and it's okay there's nothing
wrong with getting acquired but like
um or just never having done it to begin
with it's like uh you know join
something that's already working and
then say uh you know
yeah I I led blank at this company right
like there's like lots of like career
lies like that I can't think of an
example of somebody who sold their
company for let's say 10 million dollars
and said it was 50. I personally I don't
know I gotta ask you which friend we're
talking about over here uh I have a
feeling I have a feeling I know who
you're talking about but most I would
say
um
I I don't think they do that I don't
know do is this common
um well I think like it's common to
round up which is no big deal because
like yeah there's always like uh little
details about it where regardless of how
you look at it it could be true I'll
tell you in our case we sold to Twitch
um when we saw people to Twitch I've
said this many times like I gave a
presentation at your conference called
how to sell a failing company right
which was basically saying like we sold
a company that wasn't like
Instagram where it was so hot it was the
next big thing and then Facebook comes
to buy stuff for a billion dollars
that's one type of sale there's another
type of sale which is like a business is
kind of working not really it's it's
okay it's good but it's not gonna be
huge and you find a good landing spot
for it for for the asset and the talent
and when we sold to Twitch
um there was a reported number that came
out that said uh we sold for 25 million
dollars we did not sell for 25 million
dollars we sold for who got that number
uh I know how they got that number which
was uh somebody I know submitted a tip
to one of the thing one of the one of
the news sites or whatever and I don't
know if they put that number in or they
asked them and they hinted at some
number and like the journalists just ran
with it so dude another person which I
never told them to do they just did it
they were trying to be helpful they were
like hey this is whatever they asked for
this or they they asked to comment and I
just kept it you know I think they might
have just been like yeah rumored rumored
to me what you'll know like so for
example with our sale there was like
some numbers that were on in headlines
it was way lower and then there was
others that was way higher and I'm like
right I have no idea how you guys got
this information but what you'll notice
is that someone will write an article
TechCrunch will say this was sold for
made up number 30 million dollars and
then it'll they'll say rumor and this
other person will say this person sold
for this and then you get asked to a
conference and your introduction is he
sold for this right and then and then
it's like this other person's like
here's the 30 million dollar bad you
know what I mean it's like well it's
like it's crazy like this whole just
this is just Sprints it's a spread and
it's it's completely made up and so
whenever I um whenever you see articles
about this person's net worth when I
tell people I go look Google this
person's name net worth and every once
in a while like I've written articles
about someone's net worth like Ross
Albright from Silk Road when I like
wanted to test this Theory and so my
article will came up will come up and
I'm other people will Source uh cite it
and I go hey just so you know I made
that up it's completely fake and so
whenever you read about these other
people's net worth
just know that the network things on
Google are so far off so it's laughable
I don't think I've seen one that's
accurate to be honest with you I anytime
I have any idea about someone's net
worth and I Google it it is so far off
it's actually like just completely
misleading it's a if it tells you one
thing it said it's not that number yeah
a process of elimination we know it's
not that it's last again that stuff but
when we sold the even myself I can't
tell you exactly how much we sold for
why because the deal has like so many uh
different numbers there's a up front you
got this many millions of cash okay cool
but then we also got a big signing bonus
for uh first for agreeing to come on
board and enjoy the team then you got
your salary but that's not part of the
deal uh in your normal rsus from the
from the thing but then we got deal rsus
on top and then you're like okay so
which one is it and then by the time
those vested the stock price had doubled
so I was like well did I should count it
from when we got it right but I made but
I received more than the number that
that was when it was granted but so
which one is it and then for example we
had another deal with uh Facebook and
Facebook's deal was one extra year so
like twitch was three years this was a
four-year deal and so that number the
headline number of what we got offered
there was bigger but in actuality it's
like well yeah you got to stay for four
years to earn all those rsus are you
gonna even do that uh you know like some
of the rsus we got uh my co-founder
bounced after one year so he didn't even
get the other two years so you know
which which number was it the number he
got or the number that was granted or
the number that it was worth on the day
that yeah that's why I said that's right
about what rounding rounding is
different because it's like I don't feel
like telling you it's complicated and
explaining so I'll just like make
something up that's ballpark or
directionally correct
do you want to go to some of your other
topics or save them
um let's do
this AI body doubles thing so
I've now seen this trend of
people doing
startups that are I'm calling like body
doubles or stunt doubles so first there
was a bunch of news the other day about
this SnapChat
influencer girl named Karen Marjorie and
she partnered with some AI company and
they created a um an AI version of her
voice so her fans could text with her
and they could get audio notes from her
in her voice uh generated by AI
um for a dollar a minute and she made 72
000 the first day off of a thousand
users and so on then the news
Karen's a real person right I'm looking
her up she's a real person okay yeah her
last tweet uh is a tweet that says
because I looked her up just before this
to just do you know some research and
she uh last week was I love the ocean
and then it was just a picture of her
butt so
so what's something about content
creation from everybody so
she
like smoking but is that why she's
famous just for being pretty yeah I
think she's cute and that's like the
fame I don't know maybe she has some
other backstory I'm not sure a fellow
ocean lover yeah I like the ocean too
huh
let me try this
so so she made 72 Grand the first day
the news runs with this why because
anything that's like AI good or AI bad
is gonna get like published in close
City right now
um but there's other ideas that are like
this so I talked about AI Santa I was
like somebody needs to make a a Santa
Claus through
um text-to-speech and then charge people
you know 35 dollars forty dollars to
come to the website type in a greeting
saying hey wish my kid you know Stevie a
happy Merry Christmas and tell him he's
been a good boy and he did a great job
with his soccer season and like just
have Santa say all that so like I think
that's a that's a business there's a
more General version of that which is
cameo through AI so celebrities
like the idea of Cameo but can't there's
a reason that Cameo is all kind of like
c-list sort of celebs Cameo is the best
place to see which which celebrities
broke
like it's like it's a real-time net
worth calculator yeah that's
the best place to go to see who who is a
great place to go see upcoming celebrity
divorces yeah
who's got bills to pay
um Kevin from the office so it's like
there's a reason why it's see this
because it takes a lot of time like you
know uh George Clooney doesn't actually
want to sit there and record you know uh
birthday messages for like you know 33
year olds uh it's not not what he wants
to do with this time but if you bought
me a cameo by the way Gilbert Godfrey
you bought me a cameo and he just made
fun of my penis size and yeah a little
too vulgar but yeah I thought it was
great I loved it I thought it was
awesome I thought it was a good wedding
gift
I couldn't make it to your bachelor
party so I sent you Gilbert Godfrey the
The Cameo so
I think that what's gonna happen is
celebrities are going to start licensing
their name and face and voice to
companies who will pay
to be able to generate AI versus that
and go sell it for them so now you get
the residual revenue from your name and
face just like slap my slap my face on a
bottle of sprite or whatever and it
sells more Sprite people are going to do
that with can't like Cameo like Services
where it's uh it's wish me happy
birthday it's congratulate me on this
um and you know there'll obviously need
to be some rules and boundaries around
what it can and can't say but whether
Cameo itself does this or a competitor
Cameo comes out and does this with AI
like for sure this is gonna happen it's
a like obvious idea we've been talking
about this for a long time actually with
like we said that uh somebody should do
Cameo with like Pixar characters or like
Disney characters and just get the
licenses for it it's the same thing but
now you can animate anybody not just a
Disney character and before chat chat
gb2 was a thing there was another
company that we talked about that was
doing uh like AI girlfriends and a
replica how are they doing do you know
they're crushing really crushing yeah I
read an article that they like changed
something and that one of their users
killed themselves they update the model
so like as machine learning improves or
that when you know you go from GPT 3 to
gpd4 they upgrade the model and then the
users are like
my girlfriend is different like she's
saying different things to me what the
hell and like sometimes it's censorship
like she won't say this thing she used
to say she says she's not allowed to say
that or talk about that anymore or it's
like her personality changed and I'm
like heartbroken it's crazy like people
are like you go to the Facebook groups
or the subreddit it's people are losing
them the Facebook group is crazy I've
been on that for since it started and
it's really really interesting I talked
to the founders she was really cool
really smart woman I think she used to
be like a journalist
um she was like a she was like a famous
journalist in Russia or something and
then she had to flea Russia or left
Russia and then like reinvented herself
and like created became an entrepreneur
it sounds like a James Bond villain I
like I like the beginning of the story
like Russian journalists who flees
starts AI company right it's not Natalia
but it could be yeah this is great yeah
she she's really impressive uh I really
wanted to invest but the valuation is
like super crazy so you you know because
because they're like a consumer AI
company that actually has a bunch of
traction and a bunch of Revenue which is
like pretty unheard of so so the
evaluation was was like in the hundreds
of millions pretty pretty quickly
um
anyways uh there's another version of
this AI body double thing happening in
the business space so people have
approached me saying hey we trained AI
on the podcast and so now if somebody
wants people a lot of people want your
advice or whatever
um they'll pay and the AI will give them
the answers and it'll give them it to in
your voice in your style and you don't
have to take time to do this what's the
company called that does that
Delphi like uh with delphi.com
d-e-l-p-h-i.com uh so they're they're
digitizing uh they're a digital cloning
platform that can capture how someone
thinks making their knowledge
experiences and opinions available to
others in a personalized way do they
need your permission or no I would think
actually no
I think eventually they will so like you
know they can get away with it you know
right now and with a certain set of
people but like if they get big and you
realize hey they're using my name my
face my voice and charging other people
for it I'm getting nothing you know
that's just like lawsuits waiting to
happen so that they you know the email
basically asking like hey are you down
for this
um
uh like he was like hey I took your
course I helped me land a job at my like
thing
um
and then
and then I started writing viral Twitter
threads based on the what I learned in
the course eventually my startup got
acquired last week and blah blah blah
I'm doing this new thing I was like wow
that's this is crazy digital digital
clones to AI clones of people AI body
doubles I think this is a interesting
little Trend to watch it's gonna happen
I'm I think the next two years are gonna
be wild I I don't think they're going to
be as wild as people think but I think
it's going to be wild I think darmesh
said something like it's not going to be
as bad or as uh great as you think and I
kind of trust him because I think that
he's very he's he's one of the few
people that has like an IQ high enough
to understand this but also has like a
ton of EQ and like understands that like
how people work he's not super biased
necessarily like uh if you listen to the
guy who runs open AI tell you you know
it's pretty safe it's like well
you do have a bias that what was
interesting was darmesh so a HubSpot
darmesh is the CTO of HubSpot
um darmesh but they had an earnings call
like three weeks ago or two weeks ago
and he doesn't talk much uh on the
earnings call he's not the CEO
um but someone asked the CEO about Ai
and she goes I'm gonna yamity goes I'm
gonna let dharmesh uh say what he needs
to say and he gives it gives his Spiel
and he gave almost the exact same Spiel
that he gave on our pod where he like
explains it and then if you go you can
go and look at the stock since he did
that talk and I think it's up 15 or
something I think it was like 420 or 400
a day before the earnings now it's close
to 500 today and then Baron just came
out with an article that said something
like HubSpot is uh you know we think
that the companies that are going to
kill it with AI aren't AI companies but
big companies that will use AI for
example HubSpot this this and this and
what's really fascinating is he's on
this pod telling us his opinion about it
then on this earnings call this Banker
asked about it and it's like man we have
access because of Twitter and all this
stuff we're able to see like what's
happening in front of our eyes and it's
very very very fascinating to see like
how he's handling all this like they
said he he basically told us how he
started chat spot which is like an AI
thing within HubSpot he's like this is
what we did and it sounds so simple but
then he like talks about it a little bit
more like corporate speak on the analyst
calls and right you know created
something like a billion dollars worth
of Enterprise Value uh amongst other
things but right so it's like really
cool to see all this happening uh in
front of everyone I wonder what he does
after the call he's like well I guess my
work for the day is done generated a
billion dollars of value for the company
okay uh you know actually after you sold
the hustle to HubSpot I uh tuned into
their first earnings call because I
thought you might be on there just
what's up fam uh yeah Sam here are we
doing we're doing [__] great what do
you mean yeah yeah there's all these
dumb companies out there
Sam leading the earnings call dude
there's one earnings call shout out to
Marathon Ranch
all of you analysts are welcome you guys
will see a new tattoo with my dog on my
leg
[Laughter]
one time before one of these calls he
went into like the the slack of HubSpot
and he goes all right everyone I'm gonna
say the word I forget what it was but it
was like penguin eight times on this
call and so I was like oh [__] I gotta
listen to this until I tuned in and he
said the word like he threw it in and
I'm just like so funny like this guy
he's the best man this is this is my
type of guy just like he's he's winning
the game but he's having fun he's having
fun I'm a big fan of him um I think
that's it is that the pod that's it
that's the pod
[Music]
foreign